now James Bond is dead oh no wait he
flies through the fireball unscathed
hello my name is Vincent Aiello I am a
retired United States Navy fighter pilot
spent about 25 years in service flying
mainly the f-18 Hornet and Super Hornet
also had a chance to fly the f-16
Fighting Falcon or Viper had a tour as a
top gun instructor and we are going to
take a look at flying scenes from ten
popular movies
in our first scene here Harry Connick
jr. turned fighter pilot is struggling
with his mass the masks that we wear are
very constricting now granted they're
providing 100% oxygen at positive
pressure which is great but they're
still on your face and they're
constricting and you can get a little
claustrophobic of course once you've
flown in a while you get used to them
but if you begin hyperventilating you
might feel like you just need to release
some of that pressure and I believe
that's what's happening here
[Music]
they might have taken some liberties
with the maneuverability of the f-18
down low and how difficult that can be
when you don't know exactly what the
canyon does whether it just turns and
stops or turns 40 degrees 90 degrees
this is not a display that we have an
f-18 the reserve fuel which we don't
have when you get to zero you're done we
don't have drogue chutes on the f-18 to
slow it down like a b-52 or an f5 but
it's compelling to jettison the drogue
chute into the face of the attacking
alien with you're almost out of fuel
aircraft you eject and then ideally
you're gonna go high enough to not hit
the wall yourself it just crumbles into
this big puddle of man you survive the
ejection only to break your back on
landing in flight school every aviator
is taught a PLF a parachute landing fall
you want to land on your feet with a
little bit of a side and then go to your
ankles your calves your hip your your
side and your shoulders and you want to
kind of roll it out almost like maybe
what a karate maneuver would be if you
were thrown my guess is they took an
actual parachute and probably a
200-pound dummy and had him falling here
which is why he's just kind of hanging
there limp like a scarecrow fun movie
but I'm gonna give it a 3 out of 10
she's got a big on his tail now the
names that characters and aviation
movies call each other actually those
are real those are called call signs
they're basically a fancy name for
nicknames
besides being fun and funny these call
signs are nicknames they're actually
really useful they D personalize the
situation and they remove rank talking
about every little thing you're doing
it's just gonna clobber the radio's it's
gonna make it very difficult for someone
to say the things that are important
that need to be said
ie I'm defensive or Fox 3 if you're
taking an active missile shot Fox 2 for
an infrared shot now you see maverick
decided to go ahead and get back in the
fight and the controller on the ship
instantly recognizes that just because
he happens to turn left a few degrees
the radar the air search radar on the
nimitz-class carriers is the ANS PS 48
it's an air search radar has about a 200
mile range and at its highest rotation
rate has about 15 revolutions per minute
or one every four seconds well at that
range with that update rate there's no
possible way this controller understands
that maverick is suddenly back in the
fight just because he happens to roll
left a few degrees and maneuver back
now the quote-unquote make 28 in the
scene is played by an f5 couple f5 one
is a two-seater
now the f5 freedom fighter better known
as the tiger 2 in real life has twin
barrel cannon mounted on the front of
the nose not a Gatling gun style as
depicted and it might make a little bit
more of that standard machine gun style
sound but in reality for what they
depicted that Gatling gun is going to
come out with a much higher rate of fire
[Music]
I've never seen an aircraft even Russian
aircraft that are controlled with the
left hand there's a couple editing
mistakes so example you hear Iceman say
he's passing between us and it's the
mig-28 that passes between us and then
you see from Mavericks point of view two
aircraft with one go down the middle
while the other aircraft is another MIG
28 or f5 and so that didn't really make
sense wider in the back seat saying
check the guys at the left three o'clock
while he's looking out the right side
and in fact right three o'clock would
have been the right thing to say there
isis shot I'm on his tail and then the
very next clip is the f5 chasing the
f-14 where you can clearly see it's the
f5 that's behind the f-14 and not vice
versa
so overall Top Gun of course is a fan
favorite I've enjoyed it since I was a
young man and I'll have to give this
scene let's call it a 7 out of 10
I love that they brought in the f-35b
relatively new when they film this but
my question is if you had high-power
rifle and almost unlimited rounds and
you could employ against someone you're
trying to take care of from even 50 feet
a hundred feet why would you go up and
get in a phone booth with them where now
the gun is unwieldy and it can turn
around you and stick you in the back
with a knife you've got the advantage he
could have gone about a half a mile away
and seen the entire scene in his
heads-up display you know we see
examples of people trying to hold on to
aircraft I've never tried this now I do
know from walking around on top of the
f-18 Hornet on occasion that the
surfaces well they're smooth there are
various nooks and crannies and openings
that someone could get a hand hold a lot
like a rock climber on a wall but add to
that acceleration of moving aircraft and
the momentum and the wind and all that
this would be a pretty difficult task
I'm going to give you a 1 out of 10 for
this scene and you can deal with me Doug
masters
[Applause]
anything else you want to send over wait
a fly dog that Hollywood thinks a simple
aileron roll is going to defend your
aircraft from almost anything that's
happening somebody pursuing you a shot
at you if you just do a quick aileron
roll you're fine
yeah not so much I don't understand why
they can't get the gun sounds correct I
mean I guess we're all conditioned to
hear the individual bullets sounding but
in fact with a high rate of fire like
the m61 cannon in the f-14 it fires
6,000 rounds a minute that's 100 rounds
a second you don't hear individual
bullets you just hear that ZZZ sound
when an aircraft is directly at your 6
o'clock there's almost nothing harder
for the defendant in this case because
no matter what you do theoretically the
other aircraft can follow you I mean as
long as the performance is not grossly
worse in the attacking aircraft and yet
we have the scene where dad being the
good dad that he is just some happy talk
come on Doug you can do it let's let's
take care of this guy let's take this
guy out and magically the next moment
we've got dug in the f-16 behind the bad
guy a dogfight you're limited by physics
I mean that's a dumb thing to say but
you are I mean you can't just
instantaneously swap positions traveling
200 to 400 miles per hour
you can't just suddenly trade spots hit
the brakes in a fly right by heads up
this place it actually is real f-16 Hut
symbology we don't have to go through
all of it but you can see airspeed and
altitude you can see heading you can see
gee the one thing they mix up though is
towards the bottom off to the left you
see the letters si em that's sim that
means you're in a simulated war mode
that's what we used to do in training
I'm gonna give it a 3 out of 10 though
for this particular scene
[Music]
the f-15s love to fly in what's called
an eagle wall they might have as many as
12 Eagles in this wall but what they
won't be is right next to each other as
you see depicted they might be a mile up
to 2 miles apart off each other's
altitude because that way they can't be
so easily targeted then you see the
afterburners stage in and of course
Hollywood loves to show any fighter jet
ever in afterburner you've got to have
some orange glow behind it but the
acceleration here probably a little bit
artificial yes afterburner does provide
some extra thrust and it's wonderful a
lot of fun but it's not gonna be like a
drag car coming off the green light
there when we go into combat one of the
things we do is we have order called
fence check new quote fence in and one
of the things you do is you turn off
your antic lesion lights and at night
you turn off your position lights only
leaving those night-vision goggle types
trip lights of green both f-15s in this
case and the mig-29s are shown with
their navigation lights
next you see the vc-25 which is the name
of the what we would all call a 747 Air
Force one don't forget is just the title
of that aircraft when the president is
on board the defensive systems on a
vc-25 are not well publicized of course
why would they they don't want opponents
to know what the president's protective
measures are I assume there are some
sort of Expendables like chaff and
flares why not just fire a bunch more
missiles or why not just sit back there
and fire the gun instead the next thing
we see is this slashing attack over the
right wing where oh lucky him it hit the
number four engine here's the crazy part
okay you've got this Lieutenant Colonel
sitting right next to you if that's a
first officer at my airline I'm a first
officer I'm fully qualified to fly that
airplane I'm not gonna sit there and
wonder where the firelight is or have
somebody on the ground tell me we need
to trim out the aircraft because with
the rudder trim here this guy should be
able to say a president I got this sir
the f-15s firing what I presume would be
am Rams that's the aim-120 air-to-air
missile there call Fox 3 which is the
right terminology the rules of
engagement clearly we are in a
self-defense situation
lots of exaggerations and liberties
taken shall we say from the point of
view of military aviation we're going to
give this one a 4 out of 10
[Music]
I've not tried this but I'm pretty sure
air-breathing jet aircraft don't fly too
well through massive fireballs plus
we're always dripping hydraulics or
fluids of some sort that are usually
flammable so not something you want to
do of course note to self if you ever
knock out the back cedar make sure you
spend the time to get him out of your
back seat
he's kind of shaking from the recoil and
I just I don't I've never flown an l-39
with gun pods
I can't imagine though that you're gonna
feel the recoil like a machine gunner
would and he's flying with his knees now
I actually did this quite often in the
f-18 the f-18 has a center stick and
it's conveniently located right between
your knees the f-16 on the other hand
has a side stick now in the f-18 if I
were busy with both of my hands I'd
never had to defend from someone trying
to strangle me but if there were times
when I needed to adjust my helmet or
maybe I was doing something with the
throttle and I was writing something on
my knee board then I could for a moment
fly the aircraft with my knees of course
in Hollywood anytime you have the main
character in an aircraft you'll always
be able to see his face no masks maybe a
clear vial is a random bad guy this
flying scene I'm gonna give it a 2 out
of 10 sorry James Bond
they actually went out like they did on
Top Gun and other movies and filmed real
flying scenes on a real aircraft carrier
in this case the USS Nimitz you have
real f-14s you have real ordnance you
have real deck personnel they're not
gonna bother with actors but aim-54
phoenix that they depict there now the
yellow band is a way to know for a live
warhead and that's why it's on the
forward part and a brown band tells you
it's a live rocket motor so when you see
yellow and brown on that white missile
which the white doesn't really matter
you know that's a real war shot aim-54
now if it was white but with blue
stripes blue means inert or if the whole
weapon happened to be blue then you
would know that that was an inert weapon
as well here we have the f-14 pilot
getting what might only be considered a
real kill frankly a zero is probably
traveling about 120 miles an hour baby
f-14 looks like doing about 300 that's
gonna be a tough shot frankly for the
f-14 pilot but given the correct
position and getting slow enough then
that could be very easily done
here you have a red shirt that's dealing
with the arresting wire usually that's a
green shirt I'm not sure why they used a
red shirt there maybe it was someone
under training but normally the
different shirts on the flight deck are
important because that way when you
can't hear you can't still tell what
someone's job is so red is ordnance
green is catapult arresting gear as well
squadron maintenance blue are the talk
and chain handlers white is safety in
LSO's Brown is playing captain's yellow
or aircraft directors you've got all
these different colors I'm gonna give
this scene an 8 out of 10 just talking a
couple points he's gonna fly away pretty
quickly I mean the bd-5j micro jets got
a top speed of about 320 miles per hour
this whole notion of missiles that can
fly next to you and continue to pursue
you until they kill you now in real life
a surface-to-air missile such as this
it's gonna go up to maybe close to 2,000
miles per hour
it's going to be able to go after it and
it's either gonna hit it or get close
enough to proximity detonate and take it
out but what it's not going to do is
come over here and say oh yeah well I'm
gonna get you and just keep following
you around and if it does miss get mad
and come back and the whole idea that we
have these angry missiles that can
follow us in this movie and others it's
just always struck me as funny because
in order to do that it would have to fly
at roughly the same speed just because
an aircraft and any aircraft is diving
doesn't mean it's going to sound like a
world war two ERA Stuka dive-bomber
because what they put particular sirens
on those aircraft that were wind driven
and at a certain speed they did wind up
like that and yes we all associate that
with death from the skies now the fuel
light here actually I love this because
the microjet only carries 30 gallons of
fuel still love the scene so I'm going
to give this opening scene of Octopussy
a four out of ten
Broken Arrow is a term used for a
nuclear weapon that has been compromised
maybe it's either been lost or dropped
inadvertently or something else
apparently it does mean we are either
being overrun or in threat of being
overrun but the idea is that it calls up
everybody it's like calling 9-1-1 as
he's talking it depicts them coming in
and attacking there's some coordination
that exists because the whole idea of
close air support is that you are in
close coordination with the folks on the
ground you are dropping right next to
them and in fact as we see in this scene
sometimes it can happen that it's too
close what you're seeing here is napalm
it's non-discriminating
as most weapons are but if dropped in
the wrong place it's gonna burn up
anything and the one thing they didn't
quite get right here is a mark 77 or
napalm canister is deliberately not
equipped with thins because what finns
do is put a spin on a weapon to make it
more accurate for the same reason a
quarterback puts a spin on a football
when he throws it I feel like they're
showing the releasing aircraft just a
little too low it shows fighters go in
both directions that might be a little
bit of an exaggeration generally you
don't want that because they could
employ against each other by accident
I'm gonna give it a 9 out of 10 just
loses a few points for the reasons we
talked about
moduli zero one
what bothers me though about this scene
is this expectation almost in Hollywood
that they can feed the audience that
somewhere in America even off the coast
of Key West as depicted in the scene our
fully armed aircraft just flying around
doing maneuvers in reality particularly
since 9/11 we do have aircraft that are
armed on alert at various bases usually
on the coasts and that is for noble
Eagle and that is a case we have another
911 but for training it looks to me like
it's really Harriers flying by this
helicopter recommend using your bodies
to take out the bridge - okay you know
normally you do want to acknowledge a
call that's made but they just felt very
scripted you see the Harriers peel off
right away presuming they're the ones
designating the target they just need to
make sure that the laser is continuously
on the bridge the entire time and then
when it hits I mean these could be
miniatures they're blowing up it looks
fairly realistic the Maverick agm-65 was
designed to go after tanks so it's got
pretty good punch and it's going for
armored targets so against cement yeah
it might do pretty well of course the
harrier keeps flying later you've got
Dana the daughter of the hero here and
some more gunfire and aim-9 shots really
love the scene overall I'm gonna give it
a six out of ten for True Lies
[Music]
you